what did he tell you was important to
him a number of things and I'm not sure
that I'm at Liberty like share every
single one but what I will tell you is
he said Viola Davis is going to be my
mother which is kind of like choosing
Michael Jordan for your basketball team
do you typically make it a habit of
showing up at people's front doors
unannounced I call Chris Tucker and he
was like who I've always thought was a
genius and wanted to work with and he
was like I know Howard would white best
day of my life you know Howard turns out
later Chris Tucker knows everybody
literally everybody why do we not see
Michael Jordan in this movie we don't
see Michael Jordan for the very what was
obvious reason to me which is that this
is a movie about an icon about somebody
who's so meaningful that the minute you
know I show you somebody and tell you
like hey that's Michael Jordan
no it isn't I know what Michael Jordan
is I know what he is and not only that
the only actor who could play Michael
Jordan was a little old to play this
part and we probably couldn't afford him
but the idea was like if I show you
something that you know that's not
Michael Jordan and now everything else
is fake